so I just filmed this whole 20 minute
review of the Samsung S 20 altra out of
focus
what's going on guys my name is David
Tomich and welcome back to the channel
today we're talking about the s20 ultra
and my experience over the last three
months the fact that I'm starting this
video with an out-of-focus complaint is
the very reason why I'm making this
video so today we're gonna be talking
about my personal experience using this
as my daily driver from everything from
the display all the way down to the
battery quality how I found it to be in
a day to day situation and all the
little bits and pieces that I found not
worth the 2000 Australian dollar price
it cost today in 2020 so first of all
let's talk about the display and start
on a positive note the display is
phenomenal the 120 Hertz refresh rate
the color clarity the sharpness
everything about this screen is so
appealing to the eye it is by far the
best screen I've ever seen on a
smartphone
now I'm no mkbhd and I haven't seen
every single smartphone on the market so
I can't say it's the best in the world
but it is definitely the best I've seen
in my personal life time as most of you
are probably aware you can't use 120
Hertz on this device at its highest
setting Samsung just doesn't allow you
unfortunately it says that it drains the
battery too fast but I personally would
have liked to see that option as just a
yep okay whatever that's my fault
and my risk if I lose 50 cent battery in
half a day instead of only using 10% but
that might come in a later software
update so let's stay tuned and keep our
fingers crossed unlocking this phone has
actually been quite a pleasure having
the under glass fingerprint reader in
conjunction with the face unlock has
made it very simple to unlock this phone
at any given time having the position of
the under fingerprint reader as such a
small central location probably isn't
the best I would have liked to see it a
little bit better and it didn't take me
about a week to get used to the position
but after that time I really was able to
unlock this phone very fluidly almost
9% of the time with either the
fingerprint scanner or the face unlock
it's very rare that I have to use the
password anymore so that is definitely a
good feature and something I'd like to
see continuously improved so that after
a little bit of time we don't really
even have to touch it properly to unlock
the phone but when we do unlock the
phone and open up a camera app you're
probably going to see the same issues I
experienced today and every other day I
record a YouTube video the s20 ultra has
such a huge sensor in such a small
device that its depth of field isn't
perfect and it's focusing in 4k
especially video recording mode is
average of s what you'll find because
that's what I found and many many other
users have found as well is the fact
that it can't focus very well on
close-up subjects or faraway subjects in
4k or ake a video recording it doesn't
have auto face tracking it doesn't have
auto subject tracking so if I was to
move around violently in this video it
wouldn't stay in focus I don't want to
because of the very simple fact that
I've just managed to get it in focus
again so if I move too much and get it
out of focus well then it's gonna take
me 20 minutes to bring it back into
focus and get it right for you guys as
it is I'm already using an iPad with the
screen mirrored so I can actually keep
an eye on it because I'm so sick of
repeating myself a hundred times over to
make sure everything's in focus even
when we're talking about photography of
small objects or up-close objects the
main 108 megapixel sensor camera is not
the best it tends to produce depth of
field and bokeh way way too early in the
object and it blurs out maybe from here
backwards instead of all the way back or
for example my ears could be completely
blurred out and the front of my face in
focus so it is having trouble finding
focus and there have been some updates
which have made it better but it still
isn't perfect which makes me a little
bit cautious and a little bit worried
that the simple fact is this is a
hardware problem and not a software
problem
the Elektra wide camera which is
definitely one of
most used and favorite pieces of
hardware on this device is only 12
megapixels it isn't the best camera in
the world it isn't the worst camera in
the world it produces very high-end
quality images but not as high-end as
the main camera I would have liked to
see a much higher speck in the ultra
wide because that's something I
personally use a lot I feel like a lot
of people like the ultra wide because it
gives it the more natural more realistic
interpretation of the world but hey
maybe the next s20 series will see that
in and the zoom camera well I'm hoping
that you've seen my last video on the
SpaceX zoom comparison it's pretty good
up to about 30 times zoom anything over
30 times zoom starts to get very blurry
very noisy and kind of unusable by the
time you get to a hundred times ooh so
it's a nice feature to have it's a nice
gimmick to show off to people but that's
about it you can't really get the best
quality images out of it
unless you have a tripod unless you have
perfect conditions unless there's no
wind and blah blah blah it's really a
gimmick at the end of the day and
something that has sold this phone to
many people so props to Samsung for
trying to get innovative technology into
phones so early but at the same time I
wish they would have waited a year or
two before they brought out this
technology before it wasn't absolutely
perfect if you're unaware this phone is
also capable of recording in 8k now I
record all my YouTube views in 4k not 8k
not 1080p not anything else
why because it seems like this device is
optimized for 4k 1080p is very noisy and
very grainy 4k the colors just aren't
right there's something wrong with the
4k settings I don't know if it's just me
maybe it's just the environment I'm in
maybe it's the studio lighting and the
backlighting but 8k just doesn't work
properly in this situation in an outdoor
situations it's pretty good but I think
at the end of the day the 4k is the most
optimized on this device and is by far
the best for everyday you
something that really surprised me was
the speakers on this device I didn't
really expect them to be amazing but
combined with the screen the dual
speakers and the Dolby Atmos system
inside it's phenomenal
like the first time I watched a YouTube
video on this device
I was mesmerized I was blown away I was
immersed in that experience I'm not
usually like that on a tablet or a
smartphone I have a full home theater
with a surround sound system so I know
what good quality sound should be yes I
know that's ironic considering most of
my videos have terrible sound but we'll
just get past that point the speakers on
this device are actually really really
good
they're crystal clear they're really
loud at times and combined with a screen
like I said they make a really good
viewing experience the fact that the
battery on this device is also super
large makes it a great complementary
feature the fast charging was something
I never thought I'd use either but the
fact that I can forget to put my phone
on charge at nighttime leave it my
bedside table instead of on the opposite
side of the room because I turn my alarm
off and then just go straight back to
sleep if it's not means if I forget to
charge at night time in half an hour in
an hour it can be fully charged or 50%
charged that means I can go throughout
my whole day and still not drain this
battery to its absolute minimum if I'm
using this device pretty heavily on a
day phone calls videos photos everything
I don't think I usually want use more
than 50% which means in half an hour in
the morning I can get my phone to nearly
full very quickly without having to
worry about charging it overnight for
hours on end so what's my verdict on the
s20 ultra should you buy it should you
wait should you just skip it completely
well personally I think that it is a
very good device the 120 Hertz refresh
rate makes it something really
pleasurable to use every single day it
doesn't hurt your eyes as much as normal
devices do but if I think if you're
buying it for the purpose of the camera
it isn't there yet the focus and depth
of field problems are too much to shy
away from the fact that it's continuous
in everyone
videos and I have to re-record things
consistently is really frustrating and
really annoying now for me personally if
this was a day-to-day device it could be
anything but because it was a device
specifically purchased to replace my
DSLR it isn't everything so having said
that I think if the iPhone 12 comes out
with 120 Hertz refresh rate a USBC
charger and a really really good camera
combination on the back to take on this
monster it might be something worth
considering if you're in the same boat
looking at purchasing in s 20 or
potentially the iPhone 12 at the end of
the year definitely wait to see what the
comparison is going to be like but at
the moment with the software issues and
potentially the secret hardware issues I
don't think the s 20 is the perfect
photography videography camera I do
think it's a great device in general
there's absolutely nothing wrong with it
besides from some very picky pedantic
bits and pieces but overall it's a solid
9 out of 10 anyway that's all for me
today guys I hope you enjoyed the video
if you did make sure you smash that
subscribe button
20:20 style help me get to that 5k
subscriber mark and when we do I'll make
sure to do another big giveaway so until
then as always I'll see you next Monday